i think this is where the vaccine
passports are going social credit scores
i think so too let me pull up this story
we got from the new york times
this is it cdc data right now vaccine
effectiveness against infection may wane
cdc studies finds federal health
officials said the new data justified a
campaign of booster shots but some
scientists disagreed saying not every
american needs another dose
what's the problem
it's just a vaccine right hmm why are
you mad ian it's just a little piece of
paper you already got it you might as
well just show it to him well
who cares it's just an app you already
got a phone with apps on it just down
there
and it's just a booster shot to your
doctor it's just a booster shot okay
look there were four lines on it from
the beginning what's wrong with the
second booster shot gotta get boosted
look look some of these people who who
are not vaccinated are spreading covid
so we set up a quarantine zone what's
wrong with the quarantine zone it's just
a camp for people that's that's that's
the way things roll oh yeah so in
australia
you know they're building the quarantine
hub in uh in the u.s last year the cdc
announced shielding i'd we have talked
talked about it before we didn't talk
about it last show and then people
reminded us the that the the cdc
proposed their shielding plan which
would create camps
for people who are at risk it's like i'm
pretty sure the unvaccinated people are
at risk i mean look if you talk to your
doctor about what makes sense for you
but i think i honestly don't think the
vaccine passports are really what it's
all about
i think it's about getting you to
download the app and then them having
the tracking and requiring the id for
you to get into a building interesting
you get your smart id things coming up
with those rfid chips on it i definitely
think they're trying to centralize and
control and um
spy on is that the right word observe
your behavior they they are so that you
can't commit crimes bro your phone is
spying on everything you do man that's
crazy yeah it's really weird and they
can i mean the satellite tech is getting
really good too they can listen to you
through from space wow listen through
your walls and stuff
i don't know if that's common but with
lasers
maybe yeah i don't know what what uh
what kind of radio waves they fire well
so so look i'll say it again
um we've had a lot of conservatives on
the show and the media accused them all
of being antibacters it's not true a
good portion of them have been
vaccinated and talk about why they
thought it was a good idea for them many
of them are having to be older so you go
and talk to your doctor and you figure
it out and we had we had kurt schlecker
on the show his doctor was conservative
he talked to him in one of the numbers
he made he made the choice for him and
that's what i'm all about i'm about
informed consent
but now we're being told he's gotta have
booster shots right so when you combine
that with the four cities that are doing
the vaccine mandates
and with the boosters
i think they're saying now that with the
booster the effectiveness goes back up
to like 84 or whatever
is this going to be a never-ending thing
now where it's not just a vaccine
passport
it's your up-to-date medical card
because what else once you open the door
to that
asking for your id and for proof of some
kind of medical history at what point do
they just start adding more and more
things to it like outside it doesn't
make sense because if it's a virus
that's mutating and it's also in the
animal population
and you can't kill it with a vaccine so
why would you why would you chase
trying to kill something you can't kill
it doesn't make any sense
well i guess some people were saying
that although
there are animal reservoirs for kovad
they haven't transferred back into
humans i don't know if that's true
that's just one of the arguments i saw
online
but we can we can just say this i mean
variants are like dr fauci has been all
over the place
all over the place how can we track what
we're supposed to do it's like hey
youtube i'm trying to be a good little
youtuber here i want to make sure people
are safe i don't want to give medical
advice what am i supposed to do when
voucher comes out every other day with
something different yeah i just saw an
article from the new york times says
those anti-coveted
plastic barriers probably don't help and
they make things worse and they were
saying it forces the air to like
stagnate and then you the viral load
increases because the air is not
circulating yeah
what weren't they saying
weren't they saying before that it was
like on surfaces they said it wasn't on
surfaces yeah yeah
and i think a lot of people
particularly early on said you know what
we're still learning about covet we give
the government some leeway
you know the guidance changes
we you know we want to trust our public
officials
i told my friends
once the public health officials decided
that
um 10 000 people in the town square to
protest
over
you know the george floyd incident or
racial injustice generally speaking once
they decided that was okay
but a church couldn't meet outdoors and
its 50 members couldn't meet outdoors
the game was lost and nobody would ever
trust either the elected officials or
the public health bureaucrats because it
was clear that they were using this
virus
for partisan means one to get obviously
to get trump out of office and two to um
you know sort of bring onto themselves a
certain power that obviously they don't
want to give up and you can see that
hypocrisy all throughout last year
people saying you know kids can't go to
school but their kids are having in
in-person instruction in private schools
yeah you know
saying again you you can't meet you
shouldn't get together with your family
for thanksgiving or christmas
but
you know them allowing you know people
as i said to cram the public square
so i'll say this
last year
i want to say it was august
um the church i was going to in dc
sued the city
to allow it to meet outdoors
socially distant mast on its own
property
and they weren't allowed to do so
at the same time the city issued a
permit
for
the sort of march on washington where
they had like 10 000 people
you know downtown and when i saw that i
was like nobody's gonna listen to these
people anymore and i think
once the public health officials and the
elected officials
um who constantly flouted their own
rules
once that became public they lost the
most precious thing
uh that they needed to manage this
pandemic which is trust and i don't
think they'll ever get it back again
it's it's true but if you look at new
york right now man these businesses are
saying you know we're just following
orders they're gonna do it yeah and and
i i mentioned this before i'll say it a
million times because this is one of the
craziest things i've i've never thought
i'd see something like this bill de
blasio's mandate means
every business in new york must
terminate any employee who has a
disability barring them from getting
vaccinated and there's a lot
there's a lot of different you know ill
illnesses or ailments or disabilities
you could have that make it impossible
for you to get this yeah you're fired
yeah that this is this is fascistic
beyond all recognition
so
i think a lot of people have seen what
was going on and they and they want to
say no to this so in many areas they
probably are just saying like i'm not
going to do it
but you look at new york and people
after all of this are still just saying
well i'll do whatever the mayor says
yeah yeah people are starting to revolt
in france did you guys see any of that
video oh have you seen the videos though
where like the cops are walking up to
people at the restaurants or when they
try to go to a supermarket now they're
being barred from going in a supermarket
yeah and then i saw one where the crowd
was rising up and yelling at the cops
yeah there was no blows struck but
it's getting hot and it's just getting
started yeah and i think um again i'm
i'm trying to think about long term
what this political realignment can look
like right so for a lot of conservatives
who may not have been as open to
[Music]
um
assertions from their left
that the police are heavy-handed and
particularly in communities of color
they are getting a taste of what that
feels like so when you're at a game and
you're supposed to be masked outdoors
and you're not and the cops come in and
force it and you say i don't want to
wear a mask and then next thing you know
you're on the ground and being tased now
you can get a sense of what other people
were saying and i think what you're
going to end up seeing
is sort of a a
a coalition building
of folks on the right who are typically
pro police
but are
definitely anti-government
lockdowns and mandates
along with
you know folks who may be on the center
left
who say the police have had expanding
powers and too much authority
for a lot of years and i think you're
going to see that coalition start to
form pretty soon i think so we did see
uh uh we did see a little bit of the
right pushing back on cops at the height
of the lockdowns last year you had uh i
think nypd were refusing to enforce
lockdowns so they brought in troopers
there was a guy at a bar he was open but
giving things away for free they're like
we don't care they they blocked the
entrance and you had a lot of uh you had
videos of some conservatives throwing
the thin blue line flag on the ground
and then stomping on it in the dirt in
front of cops yeah they weren't having
it all of a sudden churches were being
shut down cops were defending it you had
the mayor of new york paying black lives
matter in the street without approval
from the city just taxpayer money and 27
cops defending it
and so that's all okay and they were
arresting people who protested it yeah
so eventually i think
you know maybe maybe it's uh a cold
wake-up call to a lot of uh people on
the right that cops will just follow the
orders yeah yeah you know michael malus
has a pretty bold we'll just call it
bold quote where he said they're i'm
going to paraphrase i don't know
specifically but there is no law
so depraved a cop will not enforce it up
and uh up and uh to
executing innocent children whoa now
that's michael malus it's a very very
bulletin because i'm i don't necessarily
agree like i kind of think a cop is
going to be like
he has experienced soviet union
experience personal experience and so i
think i think what people need to
realize is
you're look you're thinking about a cop
right now
a cop right now is not going to do it
he's going to be like get out of here
dude are you crazy like come on we got a
line but a cop in 5-10 years when the
good cops get purged out when they
mandate vaccines for everybody and then
you start getting skeptics and hesitant
people or people with disabilities being
like i don't know about that when the
military says it and now you've got
whether or not people are right or wrong
in their decision to make a decision and
the military says bye you're out of the
military now you've got an increasingly
woke authoritarian kind of military yeah
then you will get a cop who will gladly
enforce because it's not what michael
malus is saying as the way i interpret
is it's not about cops as the individual
it's about the institution and what they
will come to represent should things get
that to that point
i hope we don't get there no we lived in
the armed society it'd be very very
unlikely that the police would throw
themselves in into that they've been
trying to take our guns
i love it yeah which is what
conservatives say this you know they'll
say look at the head of the fb the knife
behind it atf
you know he he wants to ban ar-15s and
anything with a capacity over 10 rounds
and
that's
i think
i've learned a lot um and have to have
had to go back and and
rethink what it means to be an american
what our founding documents mean
um what the second amendment means right
i get people say for hunting and
and self-defense i get it
but
tyranny
really is not something we've had to
think about as a country legitimately
for for a pretty long time and and as i
said
the the
on on the left
tyranny and particularly and i'm
thinking you know particularly you know
an african-american community will say
you know police brutality
police overreach
tyranny to us is
assault on our physical bodies for
conservatives a lot of times tyranny
means the irs is coming after me it's
very different um
i think we're starting to see
more people wake up and say you know
what the government is inserting itself
into our personal health decisions
it is trying to control how we educate
our children
um it is trying to control
whether and how and where we make a
living
and eventually people are going to get
tired of that and the same military
folks who may get purged that's how you
get people who are disaffected and
become more radical than they otherwise
would have been yeah um if if our
government would just let us live like
free people thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you